hello welcome to my garden under /
bathroom being a man of the slow-mo
profession I liked the film Inception
it's a great films good love it there
are some great slow motion maybe it's
one of them being the kick involving the
chair that tips the sleeper backwards
into the bath of water gives them like
this the falling back sensation you
getting the dream when your stomach
drops
yeah put this bathtub we're going to put
this chair here this one chair I've got
another sort of really old
Taichi I'm going to sit in lean back and
hopefully not injure myself too badly
when I fall into this and then we got
the Phantom running at 1600 frames a
second all straight yeah I wasn't going
to die
yeah we'll line you up alright you ready
to do it so we've bagged the camera with
a state of the art Tesco bag and uh how
was it commitment
you know
I feel about that that wasn't as
unpleasant as I thought it was gonna be
but yeah it's actually quite cool
yeah look awesome it's just that whoa
they look good I look good it's fun it
was finally it's a good be it kind of
scary but yeah you're gonna give it a go
well I don't have any clothes driving to
change clothes I don't live here
so all right it's okay I've got I've got
a change of clothes
well you know we already got shots of
you did it so they little [ __ ] aren't
you then ridiculous to give them clothes
do be closed immediately enough right
now how do I look yeah beautiful loving
the trousers as well track is very
fashionable bloody odd
oh yeah isn't it bloody terrified am i
doing yeah well it's been [ __ ] baby
how does that me it was cold
yeah really cold ice how was it yeah
just so good a look yeah no people well
that was bloody fun yeah and pretty much
exactly like an interception right you
know her in the guard we are a guardian
I I'm not sure I'd like to be woken up
like that if I was asleep they know it
would be quite shot yeah where am I all
right well good luck get rid of that and
I'll just
you